i just want to go into like a series
with like zero expectations
because even if you say even if i hear
something like oh this this part's
[ __ ] amazing like i don't want to
know this part of you amazing because
i just want to like experience the fact
that it's amazing
instead of like hyping it up because
then i have like then i have like
expectations to me and i don't want
expectations
to [ __ ] joey over here as joey just
started watching demon slayer
yeah finally the reason the anime man
yeah watching
demon slayer twenty two i was that
the reason why i watched demon slayer
excuse me
oh there you go the reason why i watched
demon slayer
uh was because i was not watching it but
then suddenly on twitter
dude episode 19 episode 19 yeah yeah it
was insane bro you won't believe it bro
the animation made my [ __ ] gave birth
to my child bro it fixed my
all of my aids uh
it was like i've never seen this is like
the level of hype that must have been
there for jesus's ring like
[ __ ] resurrection bro it was i i i've
never seen so much hype for something in
my life
i think that was the first time i've
ever seen an anime trending on twitter
you're like [ __ ] ninja was like bro
i'm an anime fan whole time [ __ ] like
we're just gonna call it that now the
jesus resurrection arc
yeah it was like it wasn't the second
coming of jesus probably made too many
religious references to this podcast i
just think it because you know people
feel strongly about religion
but anyway you know i watched it and the
whole time i was watching demon slayer i
was unimpressed by everything because
i was like yes i'm waiting for episode
19. yeah yeah
i'm waiting i'm saving my nut for
episode 19. and there was plenty of
really
amazing like i'm saving my money
it's like when you when you've watched a
porno right you're saving
your you know you know where the good
bit is that's not we all do it right
let's not pretend like we don't everyone
skips you know where the blow job starts
you skip let's let's let's go to
literally 10 minutes in and then let's
skip again
20 minutes okay okay
do you watch the blow jobs in porn no no
you skip past it right yeah so you skip
past it and then they're already in like
then you've gone too far because they're
already [ __ ]
fully at it you're like no no no come
back come back yeah you want to get
before they just start that right
right that's what it was right that's
what it was
it's like are you saying that episode 19
was the
post blow job it was the post part of
the porno
it was like the everything else you knew
it was like you knew it was the [ __ ]
so you're like i'm saving it i'm saving
the nut i'm saving
it you have to save it because if
if you get super hyped about something
that happened and you know better is
coming on yeah you can't you can't match
that yeah sure
i'm sorry to the female viewers who
don't watch porn uh
um
what's wrong with you you don't
discriminate here but what the [ __ ]
yeah so what what is your opinion on
demon slayer then okay so i
have a [ __ ] event it's an animation
of the decade
um so i'm not up to episode 19 yet i
think i'm
right before that joke i'm saving that
number save the nut but that's
i think that's one of the big reasons
why i decided to not watch it until
much much later because i didn't i
didn't want that hype to sway
my opinion yeah of course of course i
mean no like
i'll admit like you know because it was
everyone was [ __ ] talking about at
the time right it's definitely in the
back of my head you're like i'm
impressed with things because you're
expecting to be impressed right
right because i'm expecting episode 19
to to be the one that i know to be the
nuts
yeah to be the nut right so i'm
basically blue balls
for [ __ ] 18 episodes all right i'm
just like
it's coming this is just like hold on
it's like a jv where it's like 50
minutes of build-up
it is like but but that's i i think
that's why i wanted it
to wait until all the hype was over just
so that
the earliest stuff doesn't [ __ ]
persuade how i see the actual show i
wanted to just go into it completely
clean man i feel sorry anyone who's
doing that with attack on titan it's
like
someday someday it's gonna stop being
popular right right it's just not
it's just not happening yeah but also
because you know the manga is ending
soon or i think it's almost end i don't
know or
i think it hasn't i think it has ended
alright it hasn't yeah so it has ended
so i'm like okay now it's probably the
best time to actually start watching it
just so that
i could probably go and just read the
manga as well because i'm that guy
so i was just bored and i was like all
right you know what [ __ ] it off oh i'll
see what this show's all about
and uh it's good i mean i i enjoy it
it's it's great it's it's the cornflakes
of anime it's very
you can't hate it like it's very
inoffensive like
there is nothing inherently about the
show i dislike
but i just i mean so far i can't [ __ ]
stand zany too i'm sorry like he's just
he's just an annoying joke he does there
are lots of there are lots of people
there are so many people who sing for
zen it's and i'm like
why he's not he's just [ __ ] annoying
i guess because
i i think a lot of people can relate to
the yo hold me back because if i go set
sicko mode
i unleash my true power yeah you've done
so yeah i think a lot of people can
relate to that yeah right
i'm a [ __ ] but yeah that's what my
ultimate's off cooldown you better
you better run bro